Hi, everyone.
My name is Sean Spitzer, instructor for Epic Games
and master mentor for virtual production.
What we're going to go through here
is talk about how virtual production and the pipeline
can be used to your advantage using some of our tools,
such as Quixel Mixer and Quixel Bridge,
and some of the tools within Unreal
to be able to make world building for virtual production.
So let's get started.
The first thing we'll look at is the scope and initial setup.
For this is very important to look at your scene
and how to actually efficiently build it.
Some of the topics we're going to cover is examining workflow,
determining shots and assets, and then also using mega scans.
So first up, we're going to examine our workflow scope.
It's obvious when starting and constructing a virtual set,
the scope needs to be examined and the overall amount
of work needed.
When it comes to Unreal, it comes into play,
it actually will work as a new type of tool.
And the fact that it can fill the gap of what you would normally
use from a designated 3D package that we could use in Unreal
to be able to create our sets and in real time
have an update of our scene and to be able to use
that for our virtual production.
It fills that gap that you would normally
see from a standard workflow, as you can see here in our chart.
It bridges the gap and makes it so
that our final output is in real time
and our visuals will update on the fly.
This is ideal in this workflow and allows
us to have virtual sets in the current climate.
So we have to determine our shots in the very beginning.
It determines what's going to be or going
to have the highest priority.
Our hero shots versus our shots and items
in that camera shot, which are less important.
How many polygons are we going to have?
What's our texture resolution?
So once we determine exactly what our items and assets are,
then we can push back and move things around exactly where
we need them and also take into account
what the textures are going to be and the poly counts.
So your scene layout is going to be
huge in determining exactly how your assets will be evolving.
So using Megascans, let's go and take a look at Megascans
and what we can do to get things going in the right direction.
So let me pull up Bridge here.
And you can see in Bridge, it actually
allows us to have a quick access of all the things
that we need and want.
Now again, Quixel Bridge is free if you have an Unreal account.
It allows you to be able to access all these
and have unlimited downloads for these assets.
And at your fingertips, you can easily go to the Home button
here and see what's new on what is the new collections that
popped up within Quixel Bridge.
These are fantastic.
They allow you to get them quickly, download them,
and once they are downloaded, it will go to my Purchased area.
You can see that the colors of the icons
will change in the fact that now I can export it.
There's the export for it.
And these, and you can also favorite them too.
So you can say, hey, I want to remember this asset.
You have an icon to click on.
And you'll see in your favorites,
you'll see that now I have one, which
is this rock set, which is fantastic as you work
and edit and collect these.
So you can see also what they look like.
You can see that the size is large.
You can see that it has some openings.
And you can see that you can also
use it as an assembly piece.
You can actually put them in groups.
And you can also see down here that there
is a collection that is all connected.
These assets are all connected within this collection here.
And that's actually pretty great to be
able to work in this particular type of tool
and to be able to get this done quickly and fast.
You'll see down below, we also have our settings
we can control, such as our download settings.
We can choose what kind of texture output we want.
We can look at the models that we want too.
And you can choose your LODs.
Now this is really important to consider when
it comes to virtual production.
You want to be able to choose your LODs wisely.
If you have a larger scene and the camera's floating over
and maybe you're rendering to final pixels,
you may want a lot of these LODs.
But if you have a set that's up close
and the camera doesn't move as much
and it's really static and your actors are in front of that,
in front of that scene, you might want to limit it
to more of the zero and one polygon counts for LODs
and not have to load all of these.
Because these can start to add up after a while
if you're not careful.
So let's go back.
And in here, you can also see,
you can choose your resolution, 4K, 8K,
and keep those things in mind based on
what hero objects you need.
We also have the export settings.
So we saw the download settings here,
but there's also the export settings
and we can click on those.
And in here, we can choose if we're going to go for Unreal
or any other Disney 3D package,
we can choose the engine version that we want.
And you also want to make sure you have your plugin
going to the right directory for the version of Unreal
that you have and you make sure it goes
into the plugins directory.
The default project you want to keep that blank.
You can, you have the option to change that if you want to,
but I will easily forget as I'm in the pipe
and I'm really trying to get stuff done.
So I would leave this blank so that whatever Unreal
I have open, it will automatically export my stuff
into my scene.
You also want to make sure when you do install the plugins
for Quixel Bridge, that your Unreal is closed
at that moment.
And only open up Unreal once that plugin's all set in
and then whenever you export, we'll go into that open Unreal.
So make note of that.
We have textures here.
You can choose different surfaces that you want.
What will your 3D asset textures be
and your decals and so forth.
And they also have models here.
So what you will bring by default in your LODs.
And then finally, we have file names.
So here you can choose what your names are going to be.
So try to keep that as organized as possible.
And you can also edit that later on
if things change within your pipeline.
You'll see I'm saying the same thing here.
So I personally, again, do not have a default project
to set that in.
Keep that pretty blank.
And as I said before, you'll see check boxes
which are little check marks off of the corner
which will tell you whether you have an asset
or whether it can be downloaded and exported.
And you'll see the blue right here.
It is ready to be exported.
So choosing your LODs wisely, like I said before,
and I will re-emphasize this
because this is really important to understand
with virtual production.
And Unreal is only going to do,
and Quixel is only going to do what you tell it to do.
So the LOD is very important.
You have to determine what and how much screen time
that object's going to have.
And if that object, now LODs are level of detail
if you're unfamiliar with that.
And that level of detail is determined
how far the camera is from that object.
But if that camera never really zooms out or zooms in
or doesn't do it very much,
you want to keep the highest level of detail
for your virtual production if you can.
And that's the wisest thing to do.
And you can always go back in Unreal
if you need to generate these.
You can, maybe for another shot.
Maybe there's another shot you want to use Unreal for
and that one isn't virtual production based.
It's maybe a sweeping camera shot.
Then you can go in there and either export this out again
or simply go in here and in Unreal,
generate some more LODs to be used.
So here's a link that you'll see in our documentation
which gives you some further explanation for that.
I'm going to give shouts out here to Brendan Jones
for the donating the concept art
and King Chen for the concept art
that we'll be referencing in the next few slides.
So in the next video, we're going to be looking at editing assets
and how to work with them.
And I'll show you exactly what we need to do
to really get our stuff to come together.